[Musique]
le vote à 18 ans qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
personnellement je trouve que c'est une
bonne chose de bien je serai fort
satisfait parce que cela me permettra de
voter la prochaine fois prochaines
élections et peut-être que cela
transformera les résultats qui ont été
acquis
je suis satisfait pour les autres parce
que moi ça ne m'intéresse pas très bien
oui pourquoi parce que je trouve c'est
normal de l'instant qu'à jeunes travail
qu'on lui prend ses impôts je trouve que
c'est logique qu'elle ait le droit de
vote
s'il veut être fixé à 18 ans on bat
trouve ça pas mal mais 18 ans et
peut-être trop jeune forêt c'est
peut-être un moyen terme à 19 ou 20 ans
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
bonne chose ou pas
je pense que c'est important qu'une
pression de la population qui est contre
18 et 21 ans fiscaux
c'est important je crois que toute chose
qui aurait sans doute pu modifier le
résultat des dernières élections
d'ailleurs
moi je pense que le vote devrait être
fixé à 18 ans c'est personnes de 18 ans
travaille à cela des responsabilités
dans la vie
peut-être que ce sera valable sur dépend
des caractères des jeunes suisses ont
une mentalité évolué non mais vous
pensez que les jeunes non
le droit de
d'émettre leur avis quant à l'avenir un
bien sûr à mon avis oui vous estimez
assez mûr pour le faire oui
[Musique]